Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. Historians make notoriously bad predictors of the future. So when, in our last football-themed podcast, Tom Holland and I predicted that England would crash out humiliatingly to the Germans in the second round of Euro 2020, we knew, of course, that we would be proved comprehensively wrong. And so we were. Tom, great scenes.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。历史学家出了名地不擅长预测未来。因此，在我们上一期以足球为主题的播客中，汤姆·霍兰和我预测英格兰将在2020年欧洲杯第二轮中惨败给德国队，我们当然知道这会被证明错得离谱。结果确实如此。汤姆，真是名场面啊。
England beating Germany in a major tournament for the first time, well, first time for 20 years, but the first time in the knockouts since 1966. Great scenes indeed, which I witnessed live, but I think you didn't. That's right. As you said, in the episode we recorded on Anglo-German relations preceding that match, you said that you had to go to your son's...
英格兰在大赛中首次击败德国，好吧，是20年来的第一次，但也是自1966年以来首次在淘汰赛中获胜。确实是名场面，我是亲眼见证的，但我想你没有。没错。正如你所说，在我们录制那场比赛前的英德关系那一期节目里，你说你得去参加你儿子的……
Was that a sports day? No, it was a play. It was a play. It was a play. Yes, at the moment... I just basically have a succession of school-themed events. So sports day was about 10 days ago, and I missed something else because of Sports Day.
那是运动日吗？不，是话剧。是话剧。是话剧。是的，在这个时候……我基本上就是一连串学校主题的活动。所以运动日大约是10天前，我因为运动日错过了别的事。
And this was Mermaids against Pirates. Pirates versus Mermaids. It was the big clash that everybody was talking about, and I'm happy to report that it ended in a score draw with honours even. So I went, obviously, in a very sort of anxious way. And as I was sort of sitting there, deliberately not, you know, the clock had just ticked past five o'clock,
这次是人鱼大战海盗。海盗对人鱼。这是每个人都在谈论的巅峰对决，我很高兴地向大家汇报，比赛以平局告终，双方平分秋色。所以，我当然是带着非常焦虑的心情去的。当我坐在那里，故意不，你知道的，时钟刚好刚过五点，
so the kickoff had begun, had happened, and I was deliberately not catching anybody's eye, looking at any of the other dads or anything like this, because I was recording the match and determined to get back to watch it. And to my relief, the very admirable music teacher Mr Price gave an announcement and he said do not check your phones do not communicate anything about
也就是说开球已经开始了，已经进行了，我故意不和任何人对视，不看其他任何爸爸或者类似的人，因为我在录制这场比赛，并决心回去看回放。让我感到欣慰的是，那位令人敬佩的音乐老师普莱斯先生发布了一条通知，他说不要查看手机，不要交流任何关于
the match because some of us are recording it what a wise man yeah it was it was very impressive that to me is the mark of a great schoolmaster which it clearly is and so you managed to see it not knowing the result so I got home I didn't look out the window of the car i ran into the house the back way so i wouldn't go past our neighbor's front window where they could see they were still watching the final scenes and i didn't want to see the expression on their faces and then we watched the whole thing yeah it's brilliant it was brilliant i know this is a tragic insight into my tortured psyche. No, not at all. I can't imagine anything worse than having to miss out on that. Yeah, exactly. Well, pretending to take an interest in your son's play.
比赛的事情，因为我们当中有人在录制。多么明智的人啊。是的，这非常令人印象深刻。对我来说，这就是一位伟大校长标志，而他也确实当之无愧。所以你设法在不知道结果的情况下看到了它。我回到家，没有看车窗外，从后门跑进房子，这样就不会经过邻居正面的窗户，因为他们可能会看到，他们当时还在看最后的决赛片段，我不想看到他们脸上的表情。然后我们看完整场比赛。是的，太棒了。这太棒了。我知道，这是对我饱受折磨的心理的一种悲剧性的洞察。不，完全没有。我无法想象错过那场比赛会有多糟糕。对，确实。好吧，其实是假装对你儿子的演出感兴趣。
I'm sure you did take an interest in the play. I did take an interest in the play. I mean, yeah. Well, I... Not to boast or anything. He's going to boast? I'm going to boast. I was rather stressed. I needed England to win in full time.
我相信你确实对演出感兴趣。我对演出确实感兴趣。我是说，嗯。好吧，我……不是为了吹嘘什么。他要吹嘘了吗？我要吹嘘了。我当时压力挺大。我需要英格兰在常规时间内赢球。
Because? Because at seven o'clock, I had to go and interview Francis Fukuyama. The end of history. The end of history. And I'd already put him off an hour. That was the best thing to do. Francis Fukuyama, a Greek football,
因为？因为在七点钟，我得去采访弗朗西斯·福山。历史的终结。历史的终结。而且我已经把他推迟了一个小时。那是最好的做法。弗朗西斯·福山，一个希腊足球迷，
a big admirer of the Euros. So we started talking. I was rather intimidated to be talking to this, you know, this great luminary. So I didn't, at the beginning, explain why I'd pushed it back an hour and why I had a big smirk on my face. St. George's Cross painted on your face. Yes. So I didn't explain that.
欧洲杯的超级粉丝。于是我们开始交谈。与这位（你知道的）伟大的泰斗交谈，我感到相当畏缩。所以在开始时，我并没有解释我为什么把时间推迟了一个小时，以及我为什么脸上带着灿烂的笑容。脸上画着圣乔治十字。是的。所以我没有解释这一点。
And then by the end, things had sufficiently warmed up that I gave the reason. And of course, his whole thesis is that the end of history means that... England has won. Well, essentially, the violent passions and rivalries that previously had convulsed European history are now at an end. Francis, you're quite wrong. No, but he's all in favour of international sporting competitions because he thinks that that preserves the end of history because we're channelling our passions and our enthusiasms into abusing each other on terraces rather than kind of bombing Hamburg. That's absolutely balderdash though. I mean, the football war in Central America. Are you calling Francis Fukuyama what he said, balderdash and also the breakup of the breakup of yugoslavia was preceded by
然后到了最后，气氛足够融洽了，我说明了原因。当然，他的整个理论就是历史的终结意味着……英格兰赢了。好吧，本质上，以前曾震撼欧洲历史的暴力激情和敌对情绪现在已经终结了。弗朗西斯，你大错特错了。不，但他非常赞成国际体育赛事，因为他认为这维护了历史的终结，因为我们将我们的激情和热情引导到在看台上互相辱骂上，而不是去轰炸汉堡。不过这纯粹是胡说八道。我是说，中美洲的足球战争。你是在说弗朗西斯·福山——他说的那些是胡说八道，而且南斯拉夫的解体、南斯拉夫解体之前也有
you know the sort of signs of it were on the football field the um future croat captain zvonimir boban fighting riot police in about 1990 um was he's often used as a as a harbinger of of the of the bloodshed to come i i didn't i didn't tell him that you should have done you should have done you missed your chance he He's Francis Fukuyama. Yeah, but you're Tom Holland. Have some faith in yourself, man.
（你知道的）一些迹象出现在足球场上，大约在1990年，未来的克罗地亚队长兹沃尼米尔·博班与防暴警察搏斗，嗯，他经常被用作血腥冲突即将到来的先兆。我没有——我没有告诉他这个。你本该告诉他的。你本该告诉他的，你错失了良机。他是弗朗西斯·福山。是啊，但你是汤姆·霍兰。对自己有点信心，老兄。
Have faith in yourself. Who am I to lecture Francis Fukuyama on sport? Anyway, this is all by the by. The reason that we're back here with, with a special is that England are meeting Ukraine in Rome. And so we did an episode on Anglo-German relations, which obviously there's quite a lot to
对自己有点信心。我算什么人，怎么能对弗朗西斯·福山的体育观点指手画脚？不管怎样，这些都是题外话。我们带这一期特别节目回归的原因是，英格兰将在罗马迎战乌克兰。因此我们做了一期关于英德关系的节目，显然有很多
talk about anglo-ukrainian relations a bit more of a challenge isn't it there's more than you'd think i mean ukraine is let's start off by saying ukraine is an unbelievably interesting country i mean uh kiev and rus as it began and part of the very dramatic attack by the mong so it's got viking stuff which i'm sure we're going to come backed by the Mongols. So it's got Viking stuff, which I'm sure we're going to come back to, sort of Viking involvement. Then it's totally destroyed, isn't it, by the Mongols. Becomes part of the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
要谈论英乌关系就更具挑战性了，不是吗？其实比你想的要多。我是说，乌克兰，我们先从乌克兰是一个难以置信的有趣的国家开始说起吧。基辅罗斯的起源，以及蒙古人非常戏剧性的进攻中……所以它有维京人的历史，我确信我们会回——被蒙古人击溃。所以它有维京人的历史，我确信我们会回过头来谈论，比如维京人的卷入。然后它被蒙古人彻底摧毁了，不是吗？成为了波兰立陶宛联邦的一部分，
which I always think we should do a podcast about because it's just such a strange state. Carved up between the Austrian and Russian empires. I mean, there's so much to talk about with Ukraine, actually. I mean, admittedly, we haven't quite got mentioned the English elements, but we'll come to that. Okay. Well, I'm going to say something provocative,
我一直觉得我们应该做一期关于它的播客，因为它真的是一个如此奇特的国家。被奥地利和俄罗斯帝国瓜分。我是说，关于乌克兰其实有太多可聊的了。当然，我们还没怎么提及英国的元素，但我们待会儿会说到。好的。好吧，我要发表一个挑衅性的观点，
which is that if Ukraine beat England, football will be going home. A ludicrous view, and I'd like to hear you justify it. Okay. I will do that. So the word football, compound word, foot and ball. Thanks for that. What are the origins of these words? What's the etymological ancestry?
那就是如果乌克兰击败英格兰，足球将会“回家”。这是一个荒谬的观点，我想听听你如何证明它。好的。我会做到的。所以“football”这个词，是一个复合词，由“foot”（脚）和“ball”（球）组成。谢谢你的科普。这些词的起源是什么？它们的词源学渊源是什么？
Well, English is an Indo-European language. And where is the homeland of the Indo-Europeans? Is it the steppes of Ukraine? It is. Yeah, southern Russia and the ste the homeland of the indo-europeans is it the steps of ukraine it is yeah southern russia and the steps of ukraine so above uh the caspian and the black sea i mean that's the almost overwhelming consensus right it's it's obviously there are people who think maybe the europeans came from anatolia or from atlantis or ind India or but but generally that's the consensus opinion so that means that um that basically so the word foot yeah the the original the the kind of you know we don't know what the proto-Indo-European word was but linguists have kind of basically worked out that it was something along the lines of pods or ped so you get you get you know that you get that in latin and greek in transcript you get
好吧，英语是一种印欧语系语言。印欧人的发源地在哪里？是乌克兰草原吗？是的。没错，俄罗斯南部和草原——印欧人的发源地是乌克兰草原吗？是的。没错，俄罗斯南部和乌克兰草原——也就是里海和黑海以北。我的意思是，这几乎是压倒性的共识，对吧？很明显，有些人认为可能欧洲人来自安纳托利亚、亚特兰蒂斯或印度，但总的来说，这是共识意见。所以这意味着……基本上，“foot”这个词，对吧，最初的……那种（你知道的）我们不知道原始印欧语是什么，但语言学家基本上推算出它类似于“pods”或“ped”，所以你会发现（你知道的）你在拉丁语和希腊语中能找到它，在梵语中你能找到
pa in french um and the germanic strand the p turned to an f but the best one is ball and it was in old english it was bial yeah in proto-germanic, apparently it was balus. And in Proto-Indo-European, it was bial, which apparently meant blow. Say that last one again. Bial. That's how they spoke on the steps of 4,000 BC. Okay. And that meant blow, inflate, swell. So it's a kind of, you know, like a blown up ball.
法语中的“pa”，嗯，在日耳曼语支中，p变成了f。但最好的一个是“ball”，在古英语中它是“bial”，嗯。在原始日耳曼语中，显然是“balus”。而在原始印欧语中，它是“bial”，显然意思是“吹”。把最后那个词再念一遍。“Bial”。4000年前草原上的人就是这么说话的。好的。它的意思是吹、充气、膨胀。所以这是一种，你知道的，就像一个吹起的气球。
Okay. But Tom, this is a claim you could make about almost anything, right? I mean, you could claim dishwashers were Ukrainian because the word for dish comes from the Indo-European. If I was doing a podcast about Anglo-Ukrainian attitudes to dishwashers, that's exactly the argument I would make. But since this is prompted by a football football match i'm focusing on football so okay football will be going home yeah well the word i mean not the not the practice the word
好吧。但是汤姆，这是你可以用在几乎任何东西上的说法，对吧？我的意思是，你也可以宣称洗碗机是乌克兰的，因为“dish”（盘子）这个词来自印欧语。如果我在做一期关于英乌两地对洗碗机态度的播客，这正是我要提出的论据。但既然这是由一场足球赛引发的，我关注的就是足球。所以好吧，足球将要回家了。好吧，这个词——我是说，不是指这项运动，而是这个词。
yes the word i agree it's a bit of a stretch but i thought you'd be more impressed by that than no i am impressed i i mean i tell you who would have been impressed by that the late jr tolkien he was a great man yeah of course for the roots of words he would have loved that so you've you've ticked that box if he's listening which he isn't um well if he were listening he'd really enjoy it anyway classy podcast um do you have i believe i i'm confident you have something more substantive to offer about surely there must have been anglo-saxons involved in the ukraine almost certainly yes there were so so we talked about um the viking origins of kiev yeah um and the russ which mean
是的，这个词。我同意，这有点牵强，但我以为你会比这更印象深刻——不，我很印象深刻。我是说，你知道谁会对这个印象深刻吗？已故的J·R·托尔金，他是个伟人。是的，当然，对于词根，他会非常喜欢这个。所以你勾选了这一项。如果他在听的话——虽然他没有。好吧，如果他在听，他一定会非常享受的。不管怎样，这是一期高水准的播客。你有——我相信、我确信你还有更实质性的内容可以提供，关于——肯定有盎格鲁-撒克逊人参与了乌克兰的历史吧？几乎可以肯定，是的，确实有。所以我们讨论了基辅的维京起源，
rowers were basically swedes who came down the great rivers um vladimir the great yes uh and they established um kiev as a kind of um stronghold controlling the trade routes. And it became a kind of a piratical empire. And Vladimir of Kiev converts to Christianity, the Christianity that you get in Constantinople, because he didn't want to become Muslim because he couldn't drink. He thought that the cathedrals of the Latin Christians were not as impressive as Hagia Sophia. Don't they go down and they see the hagia sophia and they're absolutely astounded yeah they
以及“罗斯”（意为划船者），基本上是顺着大河而下的瑞典人。弗拉基米尔大帝，是的，他们将基辅建立为一种控制贸易路线的据点。它变成了一种海盗式帝国。基辅的弗拉基米尔皈依了基督教，也就是你在君士坦丁堡见到的那种基督教，因为他不想成为穆斯林，因为他不能喝酒。他认为拉丁基督徒的大教堂不如圣索菲亚大教堂宏伟。他们不是南下看到了圣索菲亚大教堂，然后被彻底震撼了吗？是的，他们
say they say you know i had not thought that anything so beautiful could be seen he thinks it's a vision of heaven and so that persuades him to sign up to the byzantine form of christianity and so the the um the kievan ruse are absorbed into the world world of Byzantium and they have a slightly kind of ambivalent status because the Vikings are perpetually coming down and attacking Constantinople. But as they get converted to Christianity, so they become kind of neutral, that they can be relied upon. Then this is the famous Varangian Guard. After 1066, large numbers of displaced Anglo-Saxon aristocrats, nobility, seem to have migrated to Constantinople and to have joined the Varangian Guard. And there are various reports, various kind of sagas, so on, saying that they arrive when Constantinople is under siege, presumably by the Turks. They play a heroic role in this.
说，他们说，“我从没想过能见到如此美丽的东西。”他认为那是对天堂的幻景，这说服了他信仰拜占庭形式的基督教。于是，基辅罗斯被吸收到拜占庭的世界中，他们的地位有点矛盾，因为维京人不断南下攻击君士坦丁堡。但随着他们皈依基督教，他们变得有点中立，是可以信赖的。这就是著名的瓦兰吉安卫队。1066年后，大量流离失所的盎格鲁-撒克逊贵族似乎迁移到了君士坦丁堡，并加入了瓦兰吉安卫队。有各种报告、各种萨迦（传奇故事）等等，说他们抵达时君士坦丁堡正遭到围困，据推测是土耳其人围困的。他们在其中扮演了英雄的角色。
And as a reward, the emperor the emperor says you know what can we give you and some of them say we would like to form a new england and there's a wonderful paper by the historian caitlin green who who writes fabulous stuff about all kinds of intriguing early medieval you know byzantine coins that pop up in j and so on. She's written this fantastic piece about saying, was there truth to this? Did the Byzantine emperor grant a New England to the Anglo-Saxon Varangians? And she argues that it was granted to them on Crimea.
作为回报，皇帝——皇帝说：“你知道，我们能送你们什么呢？”其中一些人说：“我们想建立一个新的英格兰。”历史学家凯特琳·格林写过一篇精彩的论文，她撰写了关于各种引人入胜的早期中世纪事物的极棒的文章，比如在英国等地出土的拜占庭硬币等等。她写了一篇极好的文章，探讨这是否有据可依？拜占庭皇帝真的把一个新英格兰赐予了盎格鲁-撒克逊瓦兰吉安人吗？她认为这块土地是被赐予在克里米亚的。
And she said, you know, there are various kind of um chronicles sagas throughout the middle ages that make reference to this um in the edward saga which is 14th century icelandic saga but drawing on apparently on 12th century material to the towns that were in the land and to those which they built they gave the names of the towns in england they called them both london and york and by the names of other great in England. They called them both London and York and by the names of other great towns in England. So there was a New York in Crimea.
她说，你知道，中世纪有各种各样的编年史、萨迦都对此做过提及。在《爱德华萨迦》中——这是一部14世纪的冰岛萨迦，但显然取材于12世纪的材料——“对于土地上的城镇以及他们建造的城镇，他们赋予了英格兰城镇的名字，他们称它们为伦敦和约克，并以英格兰其他伟大城市的名字命名。”他们称它们为伦敦和约克，以及英格兰其他伟大城市的名字。所以克里米亚曾经有一个纽约。
There was a New York and New England in Crimea, apparently. And as evidence for this, Caitlin cites various Italian charts from the 14th, 15th, 16th centuries, which mention a Londina, which is presumably London. And a place called Sissaco, which is presumably london yeah and a place called sasako which is saxon so saxon town nice which you know so the evidence there is amazing you know it's it's tantalizing yeah but i think certainly strong enough for a podcast on anglo-ukrainian well if vladimir if vladimir putin is listening to this he will be raging I mean he will have
显然，克里米亚曾有一个纽约和一个新英格兰。作为证据，凯特琳引用了14、15、16世纪的各种意大利海图，其中提到了一个“Londina”，据推测就是伦敦。还有一个叫“Sissaco”的地方，据推测是伦敦，对吧？还有一个地方叫“Sasako”，也就是撒克逊人的意思——撒克逊小镇。不错。你知道，那里的证据太惊人了，你知道的，虽然很诱人，但我认为绝对足以支撑一期关于英乌关系的播客。好吧，如果弗拉基米尔·普京在听这个，他会勃然大怒的。我的意思是，他会
cancelled his subscription because he would say Ukraine and Crimea are not the same if Ukrainian listeners are listening they will be writing well they will be ordering your books in triumph and saying but we're looking at this from the medieval perspective Dominic and Vladimir is baptized Vladimir the first Ukrainian to be Christian, is baptised in Crimea. Right. I did not know. That's interesting. So Crimea is part of the Ukrainian world then, without any question. Yes, absolutely. But that's also why it's so significant for Vladimir Putin and Russia, is that it's seen as the birthplace of Russian Christianity as well.
取消订阅，因为他会说乌克兰和克里米亚不是一回事。如果有乌克兰听众在听，他们会写信——他们会欢欣鼓舞地订购你的书，并说：“但我们是从中世纪的角度来看待这个问题的，多米尼克，而且弗拉基米尔——第一位信仰基督教的乌克兰人弗拉基米尔——是在克里米亚受洗的。”没错。我不知道。这很有趣。所以毫无疑问，克里米亚是乌克兰世界的一部分。是的，绝对是。但这也是为什么它对弗拉基米尔·普京和俄罗斯如此重要，因为它也被视为俄罗斯基督教的发源地。
Right. So when the Russians annexed Crimea, there were kinds of extraordinary photos of priests with their long beards, casting holy water onto jets and blessing the, the Russian forces as they were moving into a next Crimea. So it's, Crimea is a kind of holy place. I mean, it's the Canterbury.
所以，当俄罗斯吞并克里米亚时，出现了一些不同寻常的照片：神父们留着长胡子，将圣水洒向战机，为挺进并吞并克里米亚的俄罗斯军队祈福。所以克里米亚是一个圣地。我的意思是，它是坎特伯雷。
Yeah. Or a bit like Kosovo for the Serbs. So it's this sort of, you know, this sort of place that's become slightly detached from the, you know, it's not part of the main sort of territory. Kosovo is a battle, right? Yeah, Kosovo is baptismal, that it's the wellspring of
或者有点像塞尔维亚人的科索沃。所以这是一个（你知道的）有点与（你知道的）主要领土稍微脱节的地方，它不是主要领土的一部分。科索沃是一场战役，对吧？是的，科索沃是洗礼之地，它是乌克兰人和俄罗斯人基督教信仰的源泉，这赋予了它一种奇特的共鸣。
the Christianity of both Ukrainians and the Russians, gives it a peculiar resonance. Because it gives it, you know, it's like Canterbury or Rome or even Jerusalem. It has that kind of holiness to it. And so when Potemkin
因为它赋予了它（你知道的）就像坎特伯雷、罗马甚至耶路撒冷一样的感觉。它具有那种神圣性。所以当波将金
captures Crimea for Catherine the Great. From the Turks, from the Ottomans, isn't it? He says to her, you know, we have captured the birthplace of Russian Christianity. And this is what joins us to Constantinople. And he name references Pompey the Great. He name references Alexander. He says this joins us to the classical traditions and the Christian traditions of our Russia, Russia as the third Rome. So it's sacred. It has this kind of holiness both to the Ukrainians and to the Russians.
为叶卡捷琳娜大帝攻占克里米亚时。从土耳其人、奥斯曼人手中，对吧？他对她说：“你知道，我们攻占了俄罗斯基督教的发源地。这就是将我们与君士坦丁堡连接起来的东西。”他提及了庞培大帝，提及了亚历山大。他说这把我们与我们俄罗斯的古典传统和基督教传统联系在一起，俄罗斯作为第三罗马。所以它是神圣的。对乌克兰人和俄罗斯人来说，它都具有这种神圣性。
But of course, to most English speaking or certainly most British listeners, Crimea has a significance. The Crimean War. I mean, people don't really think about the Crimean War now, but there was a time when the Crimean War loomed so large, thanks to Tennyson and his poem, The Charge of the Light Brigade, The Valley of Death and all that sort of stuff. The first modern war, some people might say, the Crimean War. Do you think? Yes. So the Crimean War is fought by a Turkish Anglo-French alliance. Such a strange war. Yes against the Russians and it's kind of centered around Sevastopol isn't it? Yeah it's 1853 to 1856. The sort of the trigger for the war is who administers the holy places in Ottoman-occupied Israel and Palestine.
但是当然，对大多数英语国家听众、或者肯定对大多数英国听众来说，克里米亚有着特殊的意义。克里米亚战争。我的意思是，人们现在不怎么想起克里米亚战争了，但曾经有一段时间，由于丁尼生和他的诗《轻骑兵冲锋》、“死亡谷”以及诸如此类的内容，克里米亚战争显得如此重要。有些人可能会说，这是第一场现代战争，克里米亚战争。你觉得呢？是的。所以克里米亚战争是由土耳其、英、法同盟发起的。多么奇怪的一场战争。是的，针对俄罗斯的战争，它大致以塞瓦斯托波尔为中心，对吧？是的，那是1853年至1856年。这场战争的导火索是，谁来管理奥斯曼帝国占领下的以色列和巴勒斯坦的圣地。
So that's another example of how this stuff really matters. Yeah, I mean, absolutely. Who owns the holy places. Yes. It's also about French and Russian sort of national virility. They both, you know, the Russians are expanding. The Ottoman Empire is sort of breaking up. The French want to and the British want to and the british want to preserve the ottoman empire they want to stop the russians getting the straits the the sort of constantinople
所以这是这方面真的很重要 的又一个例子。是的，我的意思是，绝对的。谁拥有圣地。是的。这也关乎法俄两国的民族威望。他们都，你知道的，俄罗斯在扩张。奥斯曼帝国正在解体。法国人想要——英国人想要——英国人想要保护奥斯曼帝国，他们想阻止俄罗斯人获得海峡、通往君士坦丁堡的通道，
and the gateway to the black sea and the mediterranean um and this sort of blows up into this incredibly vicious war but also the war with railways with telegraphs with photography with florence nighting War correspondence, isn't it? The Times sends a correspondent, and it's the first one where you get reports from the front. And it's the first kind of major European war that Britain has fought, and indeed the French, since the Napoleonic Wars. And there are various kind of generals out there,
以及通往黑海和地中海的门户。这演变成了一场极其残酷的战争，这也是一场伴随着铁路、电报、摄影和弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔的战争。战地记者，对吧？《泰晤士报》派出了记者，这是第一场能获得前线报道的战争。这也是自拿破仑战争以来，英国以及法国打的第一场欧洲大战。那里有各种各样的将领，
British generals who keep getting muddled up. Yeah, they're... Let's's a let's attack the french it's completely the russians it's a bit of a shambles isn't it the crimean war so most famously and actually we talked about we've talked about him a few times so it seems mad not to mention flashman the great crimean war book i think is flashman at the charge in which flashman is in this they're thick of all the action so and all these characters lord cardigan and all these characters, Lord Cardigan, and all these people who absolutely despise Flashman are charging towards Russian guns and being massacred and so on.
英国将领总是搞混状况。是的，他们……让我们去袭击法国人——完全搞错了，是俄罗斯人。克里米亚战争有点像是一场混乱，不是吗？最著名的是——其实我们谈论过，我们讨论过他好几次了，所以不提弗莱士曼（Flashman）似乎很疯狂。《大盗麦克唐纳》中关于克里米亚战争的那本好书，我想是《轻骑兵冲锋中的弗莱士曼》，弗莱士曼身处所有行动的核心，所有的这些人物——卡迪根勋爵和所有这些人物，
So from the footballing point of view, there are two key engagements, two key approaches to attacking your enemy that the Crimean War exemplifies. So you have the Charge of the Light Brigade, which is full on, you know, let's open with Grealish, attack. That's Kevin Keegan's England, 2000.
卡迪根勋爵和所有这些绝对鄙视弗莱士曼的人，正冲向俄罗斯的枪炮并遭到大屠杀等等。所以从足球的角度来看，克里米亚战争体现了两种关键的交战方式、两种进攻敌人的方法。所以你有轻骑兵冲锋，这是全力以赴的，你知道的，让我们以格拉利什首发来开局，发起进攻。那是凯文·基冈的英格兰，2000年。
Which goes disastrously wrong. And then you've got the Thin Red Line. And Scottish listeners, I hope will forgive me, the Thin Red Line is actually, it's a Scottish regiment. It's the Sutherland Highlanders. But from the point of view of this podcast let's say british english whatever um and that's where um a russian cavalry force is
结果遭遇了灾难性的失败。然后你有了“细红线”。苏格兰听众，希望你们能原谅我，细红线其实是一支苏格兰团。它是萨瑟兰高地团。但从这期播客的角度来看，我们姑且称之为英国的、英语的，随便吧——那就是在一支俄罗斯骑兵部队
approaching they are kind of stranded it's colin campbell who commands them lines them up not in four because they don't have enough to do that that's the standard approach he lines them up in so they're kind of they're too deep And this is the thin red line bonnet of phrase. So that implies defence holding out. So I guess Gareth Southgate is a kind of thin red line man. He is, he's... Rather than a,
逼近时，他们陷入了困境。科林·坎贝尔指挥他们，将他们排成队列——不是排成四列，因为他们没有足够的人手这样做，那是标准的做法——他将他们排成两列，所以他们只有两列人深。这就是“细红线”这个短语的由来。所以这暗示着防守、坚守。所以我想加雷斯·索斯盖特是一种“细红线”式的人物。他是，他是……而不是那种，
there are your guns, my lord, attack! Yeah, exactly. So the Charge of the Light Brigade, just talk us through that, because it's such a great story. So the Charge of the Light Brigade is in utter shambles now. I haven't come prepared for this, Tom, so I'm just trying to remember it. The Russians' guns are at the top of a valley, aren't they?
“大炮就在那里，大人，冲锋！”是的，exactly。所以“轻骑兵冲锋”，给我们讲讲这个，因为这是一个如此精彩的故事。所以轻骑兵冲锋现在简直是一团糟。我没有为此做准备，汤姆，所以我只是在努力回忆它。俄罗斯人的大炮在山谷顶端，对吧？
At the bottom of a valley, I think. At the bottom of the valley, but at one end of the valley anyway. They're at some end of the valley. So this is at Balaclava, hence the nice woolen mask. And now, as I remember, the Russians are withdrawing, clava um hence you know the uh the nice woolen mask um and uh now so i remember the russians are withdrawing and the the commander says you know go and basically get the guns before they withdraw and but somehow in the course of this being relayed to the light brigade they end up pointing at the wrong guns that's right isn't it this is their real guns so the chain of command
在山谷底部，我想。在山谷底部，但在山谷的一头，无论如何。它们在山谷的某个尽头。所以这是在巴拉克拉瓦，因此有了那顶漂亮的羊毛面罩。现在，据我回忆，俄罗斯人正在撤退，克拉瓦——因此（你知道的）那顶漂亮的羊毛面罩——然后，据我回忆，俄罗斯人正在撤退，指挥官说：“去，基本上在他们撤退前拿下大炮。”但不知何故，在将这个命令传达给轻骑兵的过程中，他们最终指向了错误的大炮。对，是这样的吧？这是真正的火炮，所以指挥链
there are three lords all of whom are useless yeah so there's lord raglan that's right who fought in the napoleonic wars and he's the one who keeps saying go and attack the french it's like the fact that the french are his allies and he's about kind of 90 and incredibly doddery yeah then there's the lord lucan ancestor of the lord lucan who will he doesn't he doesn't vanish he doesn't he doesn't disappear and he I think is the brother-in-law of Lord Cardigan now Lord Cardigan is a ridiculous man who commands the light brigade uh but they detest each other yes and then there's a guy called Nolan he's the intermediary isn't he he carries the message yeah and because none of them are speaking to each other it it it doesn't it doesn't provide for great communication.
有三位勋爵，他们全都没用。是的，有个拉格朗勋爵，没错，他在拿破仑战争中打过仗，他就是那个一直说“去进攻法国人”的人——就像事实上法国人是他的盟友，而他大约90岁了，极其老态龙钟。是的。然后还有卢肯勋爵，也就是那位后来会——他没有消失，他没有消失——卢肯勋爵的祖先，我记得他是卡迪根勋爵的小舅子。现在卡迪根勋爵是一个荒谬的人，他指挥着轻骑兵，但他们互相痛恨。是的。然后有个叫诺兰的家伙，他是中间人，对吧？他负责传话。是的。因为他们互不理睬，所以这不利于良好的沟通。
And so basically there's a kind of, there's a snarl up. Cardigan says, which guns do you mean? Nolan gestures. And then I think gets shot, gets killed. He speaks firstly, doesn't he? Doesn't he say, there are your guns, my lord, or something? Yes. Go and get them or whatever. whatever pointing vaguely into the distance and the one rule of of war is that if you have cavalry and particularly light cavalry you don't use it to charge artillery head on
基本上出现了一场混乱。卡迪根问：“你指的是哪门炮？”诺兰比划了一下。然后我想他被枪击了，牺牲了。他先开口了，对吧？他不是说过“大人，大炮就在那里”之类的话吗？是的。“去拿下它们”之类的话，同时含糊地指向远处。战争的一条铁律是，如果你拥有骑兵，尤其是轻骑兵，你绝不能用它去正面冲锋火炮。
so cardigan thinks this is mad but because he's been given the order and because he is um he's just insanely arrogant and stiff-necked. He's just a Victorian British general, right? He just does what he does. Inventor of the cardigan, of course. He's the inventor of the cardigan. I think that's why he wears it over his shoulder, doesn't he? Like the kind of jacket.
所以卡迪根认为这太疯狂了，但由于他接到了命令，而且因为他……他只是疯狂地傲慢且顽固。他只是个维克多利亚时代的英国将军，对吧？他只会按部就班地做事。当然，他也是开襟羊毛衫（cardigan）的发明者。他是开襟羊毛衫的发明者。我想这就是为什么他把它披在肩上，对吧？就像那种夹克一样。
I didn't know that. I think so. That's a great fact. And so they charge down. They get absolutely devastated. And then the survivors kind of trot back. But you know what? There's now a revisionist history of this.
我不知道这一点。我想是的。这是一个很棒的事实。于是他们冲了下去。他们被彻底消灭了。然后幸存者们又小跑着回来了。但你知道吗？现在有了一种关于这件事的历史修正主义。
As with all disastrous British battles, a bit like the Somme or Passchendaele or whatever, there are military historians now who say, well, actually, you know. It was quite good, was it? Yeah, we got the results we wanted or whatever. I mean, I don't believe that. Yeah, that's very football manager.
就像所有灾难性的英国战役一样，有点像索姆河或帕斯尚尔战役之类，现在有一些军事历史学家说：“嗯，实际上，你知道的。”其实挺不错的，是吗？是的，我们得到了想要的结果之类。我的意思是，我不相信这一点。是的，这非常符合足球经理的风格。
Yeah. All right, we lost 7-0. But, you know. We've learned lessons. We go again on Tuesday. Provides a platform. Yeah. There's lots to build on.
好吧，我们0-7输了。但是，你知道的。我们吸取了教训。我们周二卷土重来。这提供了一个平台。是的。有很多值得建立的基础。
But, I mean, it's also very, I mean, I guess this is something that football, sport perhaps has inherited. We love a kind of a bloody disaster. Of course we do. Yeah. There's a book, isn't there? Heroic Failure in the British.
但是，我的意思是，这也是非常——我的意思是，我想这是足球、体育或许继承下来的一种特质。我们热爱轰轰烈烈的灾难。我们当然热爱。是的。有一本书，对吧？《英国人的英雄式失败》。
Yeah. So Gazza bursting into tears. Exactly. As we get knocked out. Yeah. I mean, it lives on in British folklore. That's why it feels slightly un-English to be making sort of unruffled progress through
所以加扎（Gazza）泪流满面。就在我们被淘汰的时候。绝对是的。我的意思是，这在英国民间传说中代代相传。这就是为什么，在一场比赛中像我们过去几场比赛那样一路顺风顺水地取得毫无波澜的进展，感觉有点不像英国人的风格。因此从某种意义上说，丁尼生的那首《轻骑兵冲锋》绝对为这种风格奠定了模板。它有一种足球助威歌的特质。好吧，我认为后殖民主义历史学家——虽然他们不是我通常会以极度压倒性的钦佩之情去引用的对象——但他们会说，这一切很大程度上是由负罪感驱动的，他们认为是这样，或者是一种不良良心，即英国人制造了这种殉难崇拜（你知道的，“哦，我们寡不敌众，我们是弱者，我们表现得像英雄一样却被打败了”），以此（你知道的）来应对这样一个事实：实际上他们只是在用加特林机枪屠杀人们。除了这一次，是因为我们极其无能。
a tournament as we have been doing for the last few games. And so in a sense, Tennyson's poem on the Charge of the Light Brigade kind of absolutely establishes the template for that. There is a kind of football chant quality to it. Well, I think post-colonial historians are sort of not people i normally quote um with enormous overwhelming admiration but they would say a lot of this stuff is motivated by guilt they think or sort of bad conscience that the sort of british create this cult of martyrdom you know and oh we're so outnumbered with the underdogs and we performed heroically and were
是的。而且我认为这实际上是另一回事。所以有很多球迷的不当行为。对管理层有很多不满，
beaten to sort of you know to sort of cope with the fact that actually they're just mowing people down with gatling guns. Except on this occasion, it's because we're grotesquely incompetent. Yeah. And I think actually this is the other thing. So there's a lot of fan misbehaviour. There's a lot of discontent with the management,
这非常“足球”，而且有球迷的不当行为。所以在英格兰，这场战争相当不受欢迎。我认为特别是对托利党人和托利党选民来说，有很多这样的场景：人们在投掷雪球——有雪球骚乱，球迷们可以说是用雪球在砸人。我想他们是在用雪球砸招募军官还是什么的。
which is very football, and there's fan misbehaviour. So in England, the war is quite unpopular. I think particularly with the Tories and with Tory voters and there's all these scenes where people are pelting there are snowball riots where the fans as it were are pelting. I think they were pelting like recruiting officers or something
然后政府——好吧，时任首相阿伯丁伯爵倒台了，接着帕麦斯顿接管了政权，当然帕麦斯顿是个喜欢攻击外国人的大人物。派遣炮舰。是的，派遣炮舰。许多城镇仍然留有克里米亚战争的遗迹。当我们在战争结束时，
with snowballs. And the government, well, the Earl of Aberdeen who was the Prime Minister falls and then Palmerston takes over and of course Palmerston's a great man for attacking foreigners. Sending gunboats. Yeah, sending gunboats. There are legacies of the Crimean War in lots of towns still. And when we finally, at the end of the war,
我们终于攻占了塞瓦斯托波尔，那里有大量旧的俄罗斯枪炮和大炮，它们都被带回国内，并被分发到全国各地。我的意思是，有些在（你知道的），有些在诸如哈特尔普尔等地。每个城镇都想要一个，尤其是那些强烈支持这场战争的城镇。所以阿宾顿有一个，加拿大其实有很多，加拿大现在大约还有20门这样的塞瓦斯托波尔大炮，
we captured Sevastopol, there's loads of old Russian guns, cannons, and they were all brought home and they were sent all around the country. I mean, there were some in, you know, there were some like Hartlepool. Every town wanted one, particularly towns that had strongly supported the the war so there's one in abingdon and there's there's loads in canada actually there's about 20 still in canada these
这有点像（你知道的）“乌拉，乌拉，我们缴获了这些老旧的俄罗斯大炮”，然后其中一些在二战中被熔化了，用来（你知道的）制造喷火战斗机什么的。所以英国各地的集镇上散落着各种诡异的（你知道的）克里米亚战争的遗物。哦，我们刚刚收到制作人的信息，维多利亚十字勋章仍然是用熔化的塞瓦斯托波尔大炮制作的。我相信这很有争议，我认为人们分析了维多利亚十字勋章，并问：“它们真的是用大炮做的吗？”老实说，多米尼克，别再毁掉我们的事实了。是的，别用你的历史真相来扫兴了。好吧，我的意思是，当然，另一个遗产是护理。
sebastopol guns um which was sort of you know hurrah hurrah we've captured these old russian cannons and then some of them are melted down in the second world war um to you know build spitfires or something so there were sort of weird you know relics of um the crimean war in sort of market towns all over england oh we're just getting a message from our producer victoria cross medals are still made out of melted down sebastopol guns that is controversial i believe i think the people have analyzed vict Victoria Cross medals and said, are they really great? Honestly, Dominic, just stop ruining our facts. Yeah, stop it with your historical truths. Well, I mean, and also, of course, the other legacy is nursing.
弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔。还有玛丽·西科尔（Mary Seacole）。是的。在某种程度上，她已经成了一种偶像，以至于她取代了弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔，尽管她根本不是护士。我认为她基本上只是经营了一家酒店。英国的每个学童现在都知道玛丽·西科尔，对吧？
Florence Nightingale. And Mary Seacole. Yes. Who, in a way, has become a kind of icon to the extent that she's replaced Florence Nightingale, even though she wasn't a nurse. I think she basically just ran a hotel. Every school child in Britain now learns about Mary Seacole, don't they?
我的意思是，这难道不是那种——但通常这段话前面都会加上这样的话：“她被从历史中抹去了，现在没有人读到关于她的东西了。”好吧，我觉得这有点……这是一个有趣的例子，说明了我们如何在21世纪继续将英国帝国历史上的传奇人物神话化。玛丽·西科尔是一个完全被神话化的人，其方式正如——我猜——卡迪根勋爵一样。卡迪根？
I mean, isn't that the sort of... But usually this is prefaced with the words, she's written out of history and nobody reads about her now. Well, I think it's kind of... It's an interesting example of the way in which we continue to mythologise people from British imperial history, even in the 21st century. Mary Seacole is an entirely mythologized person in exactly the way that, I guess, the Earl of Cardingdon was. Cardingdon?
是的，卡迪根。汤姆，你知道的，我以为这期播客花大约10分钟谈谈英乌关系就够了。部分是因为我们并没有真正大规模地讨论英乌关系。我们现在已经到了上半场的尾声。好吧，接下来会有——这确实是一场分为上下半场的比赛。我要不要以朗诵一段丁尼生的话来结束它？我觉得那绝对太棒了。所以我们将在丁尼生的诗句中结束，你可以想象——让我们希望这不会
Yeah, Cardigan. Tom, you know, I thought this podcast would take about 10 minutes on Anglo-Ukrainian relations. And partly because we haven't really talked massively about Anglo-Ukrainian relations. We've now got to the end of the first half. Well, there are going to be, it is going to be a game of two halves. Shall I end it by reading a chunk of Tennyson? I think that would be absolutely brilliant. So we'll go out on Tennyson and you can imagine, let's hope that this doesn't
预示着罗马将会发生什么。轻骑兵冲锋，可有士兵气馁？纵然士兵已知有人犯错。无需争辩，无需问为什么，唯有服从与牺牲。
prefigure what happens in Rome. Forward the light brigade, was there a man dismayed? Not though the soldier knew someone had blundered. There's not to make reply, there's not to reason why, there's but to do and die.
冲入死亡之谷的六百勇士。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是您每周必看的“冲入死亡之谷的六百勇士”节目和现场门票的抢先体验，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。您好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》英乌关系特辑。正如多米尼克在休息前所说，我以为我们可能很难凑满20分钟的节目时长。但基本上，我已经讲完了我知道的一切。我现在没有什么可补充的了。多米尼克非常自信地表示，他还有足够讲另外20分钟的内容。
Into the valley of death rode the 600. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix Road the 600. episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to a Rest Is History special on Anglo-Ukrainian relations. As Dominic said before the break, I thought we might struggle to fill out 20 minutes on this. But basically, I've said everything that I know. I now have nothing more to add. Dominic is very confidently saying he's got stuff for another 20 minutes worth.
那就开始吧。我从未想过我会听到你说出这些话，汤姆。你还好吗？你已经讲完了你知道的一切。我对外面的英乌关系一无所知。你不知道胡佐夫卡（Huzovka）吗？不。胡佐夫卡是一个如此精彩的故事。好吧，那它和顿巴斯有什么关系吗？
So give it. I never, ever thought I would hear you say those words, Tom. Are you all right? You've said everything you know. I don't know anything else about Anglo-Ukrainian relations. You don't know about Huzovka? No. Huzovka is such a great story okay so does he have anything to do with the don bass um yes and he's also not a person he's a place okay that shows how much i know okay so the don bass i did a school geography project on it wow on donetsk and uh and and the sort of coal and iron the one of the most industrial areas of europe and now of course at the center of this so that was in the 70s this war the russian
是的，而且它不是一个人，而是一个地方。好吧，这说明了我有多无知。好吧，顿巴斯——我曾经做过一个关于它的学校地理项目。哇，关于顿涅茨克以及——以及那里的煤炭和铁矿，那是欧洲最具工业化色彩的地区之一，而现在它当然成为了这场冲突的中心。所以那是在20世纪70年代，这场俄罗斯与乌克兰在顿涅茨克和卢甘斯克之间爆发的这种未宣之战。所以我做过关于芝加哥和顿巴斯的地理项目。我这两个地方都没去过，但我觉得我了解它们。你知道我做了什么吗？那是我的地理项目。我做了一个关于露天采矿的项目。你当然做了。真令人沮丧。我的意思是，我本应该做——为什么我没能做芝加哥？
ukrainian kind of undeclared war that going on in donetsk and luhansk so i did geography projects on chicago and on the donbass i've never been to either, but I feel I know them. Do you know what I did? It was my geography project. I did one on open-cast mining. Of course you did. So depressing. I mean, I should have done... Why didn't I get to do Chicago?
太有趣了。我至今仍能画出流入湖中的机场的地图。不管怎样，抱歉，我们正在……所以我一直在等待关于露天采矿的播客，但我认为它不会发生了。好吧，所以采矿把我们带到了顿巴斯。人们记得他们曾经历过——
It's so enjoyable. I can still draw the map of the airport going out into the lake. Anyway, sorry, we're... So I keep waiting for the podcast on open-cast mining, but I don't think it's going to happen. All right, so mining brings us to the donbass so people remember they had um the euro maidan revolution in um
乌克兰在2010年代初爆发了尊严革命，俄罗斯吞并了克里米亚，随后东部爆发了战斗。在这场战斗期间，互联网上流传着一则消息，上面说：“是时候让顿涅茨克——这个处于冲突中心的城市——回归了。唯一的解决办法是让它与英国重新统一。它既不应该是俄罗斯的，也不应该是乌克兰的，而应该是英国的。”你可能会觉得这很荒谬。但顿涅茨克确实是以一个英国基地的身份起家的。所以在19世纪60年代末，俄罗斯帝国正在非常迅速地发展。他们需要引进人才来实现工业化，他们与一家名为米尔沃尔
ukraine at the beginning of the 2010s and uh the russians annexed crimea and then there was this fighting in the east and during all this fighting a thing went up on the internet and it said it's time for donetsk the city at the center of this this, to be – the solution is for it to be reunited with the United Kingdom. It should be neither Russian nor Ukrainian but British. And you might think that's ridiculous. But Donetsk did begin as a British foundation. So late 1860s, the Russian Empire is very rapidly developing. And they need to bring in talent to basically industrialize it and they they do a deal with a company called the millwall
钢铁造船公司（Millwall Ironworks and Shipbuilding Company）的公司达成了一项交易，所以你很难找到一家比这更具英格兰特色的公司了。米尔沃尔钢铁厂派过去了一个名叫约翰·休斯（John Hughes）的人，不幸的是，对于这档播客来说，他是威尔士人。所以，是的，但他来自——他来自米尔沃尔，汤姆。他来自一家米尔沃尔的公司。
ironworks and shipbuilding company so you could hardly find a more english company and the millwall ironworks send over a man called john hughes who unfortunately for this podcast is welsh um so yeah but he's come from it's come from millwall tom he's come from a millwall company And the Millwall Ironworks send over a man called John Hughes, who unfortunately for this podcast is Welsh. So, yeah, but he's come from, it's come from Millwall, Tom. He's come from a Millwall company. So I think he counts. I'm sure our Welsh listeners will find us bundling Wales into England. I'm not bundling Wales into England.
而米尔沃尔钢铁厂派过去了一个名叫约翰·休斯的人，不幸的是，对于这档播客来说，他是威尔士人。所以，是的，但他来自——他来自米尔沃尔，汤姆。他来自一家米尔沃尔公司的。所以我觉得他算数。我确信我们的威尔士听众会发现我们把威尔士和英格兰混为一谈了。我没有把威尔士和英格兰混为一谈。
I'm elevating Wales above England. I think that's what I'm doing. So John Hughes goes over. He's from Merthyr Tydfil. He goes down to what's now Ukraine, and he picks his spot, and he says, this is the place, iron and coal and stuff. And he starts bringing over. The Russians don't have the skilled engineers and stuff, so he brings over hundreds of largely Welsh skilled laborers
我是在把威尔士的地位凌驾于英格兰之上。我想这就是我正在做的。所以约翰·休斯去了那里。他来自梅瑟蒂德菲尔。他去了现在属于乌克兰的地方，选好了地点，说：“就是这里了，有铁矿、煤炭之类的东西。”然后他开始把人带过去。俄罗斯人没有熟练的工程师之类的人才，所以他带去了数百名大多是威尔士籍的熟练工人和劳动力。
and engineers and miners and so on, to set up his factories. And they do. And by the end of the century, there's about 30,000 people living there, a lot of them Welsh or English. There's an Anglican church, there's an English-speaking school. So this is what's going to become Donetsk and at the time it's called Hughesovka so it's named after John Hughes and it's basically a sort of British and mixed British Ukrainian and Russian community in Ukraine and it's one of the sort of big industrial becoming one of the already one of the big industrial powerhouses of central and eastern Europe and basically continues as that until the Russian Revolution
还有工程师和矿工等等，来建立他的工厂。他们确实建了。到本世纪末，那里大约有3,000人居住，其中许多是威尔士人或英国人。那里有一座圣公会教堂，有一所英语学校。所以这就是日内瓦（顿涅茨克）的雏形，当时被称为尤索夫卡（Hughesovka），是以约翰·休斯（John Hughes）的名字命名的，它基本上是乌克兰的一个由英国人以及英、乌、俄混血组成的社区，它是中欧和东欧迅速崛起的大型工业重镇之一，基本上一直保持这种状态，直到俄罗斯革命
when all the Brits are kicked out. So, and it's extraordinary that some of them have gone from rags to riches to rags again. So they've come from, you know, nothing in South Wales. They've worked their way up. They go to, they've gone out to the Russian Empire
所有的英国人都被赶走了。所以，说实话，其中一些人的经历非常传奇，从一贫如洗到腰缠万贯，然后又一贫如洗。他们从南威尔士一无所有的地方走出来。他们通过自己的努力奋斗。他们前往了俄罗斯帝国
and they've made a lot of money and they live in, you know, with servants and things. And then the Russians kick them out and they come back to Wales with nothing. So that's an extraordinary story. And, of course, it doesn't stay as Kuzovka. It is renamed Stalino and then ends up becoming Donetsk. Is there any move to rename it, give it back its original name? I don't think so.
赚了大笔钱，过上了有仆人伺候的生活。然后俄罗斯人把他们赶了出去，他们什么也没带就回到了威尔士。所以这是一个非同寻常的故事。当然，它并没有一直叫尤索夫卡。它先是被改名为斯大林诺，最后变成了顿涅茨克。有没有人提议把它改回原名呢？我觉得没有吧。
I think basically the Russians... Constantinople. The Russians. Yeah, the Russians and the Ukrainians are fighting very sort of fiercely over it. So making it British again, I mean, making it British again would be a kind of answer, wouldn't it?
我觉得基本上俄罗斯人……君士坦丁堡。俄罗斯人。对，俄罗斯人和乌克兰人为它展开了非常激烈的争夺。所以让它再次成为英国的领地，我的意思是，让它再次变成英国的，这倒是个解决办法，对吧？
Would. You could give it an MP, could be a county, I suppose. Great, wouldn't it? Yeah. Yeah, the Donbass. And they've probably got some great footballers and then they could play for England.
确实。你可以给它派个国会议员，让它成为一个郡，我想。不是很棒吗？对吧？对，顿巴斯。他们可能有一些出色的足球运动员，然后他们就能为英格兰队效力了。
Yeah, I mean, Shakhtar Donetsk was often in the Champions League. They imported a lot of Brazilian players. I don't think they relied on local talent particularly. They're a very fetching kind of orangey strip. I think they do very well in the Premier League. I'd like to see them in the Premier League. But there's also another sort of quite weird Welsh connection. So Ukraine has this absolutely ghastly 20th century history. I mean, I read something the other day when I was thinking about this,
对，我的意思是，顿涅茨克矿工队经常踢欧冠。他们引进了大量巴西球员。我觉得他们并不是特别依赖本土人才。他们穿着非常吸睛的橙色球衣。我觉得他们在英超联赛里会表现得很不错。我很想在英超联赛里看到他们。但这里还有另一种非常奇特的威尔士联系。乌克兰拥有绝对悲惨的20世纪历史。我的意思是，前几天我在考虑这件事时读到了一些东西，
that some American scholar who's basically said there is no example anywhere in the world of a country that has sort of suffered more chaotic and miserable time than Ukraine after the First World War. So after the First World War, I think at one point there were seven different armies fighting for control of Ukraine. So there's white Russians, there's the Bolsheviks, there's some anarchists, there's the Poles, there's, I think, two different groups of Ukrainian nationalists. So it's just an absolute nightmare.
某个美国学者基本上说过，世界上绝无仅有哪个国家像乌克兰在第一次世界大战后那样，遭受过如此混乱和悲惨的时期。所以在第一次世界大战后，我想曾经一度有七支不同的军队在争夺对乌克兰的控制权。所以有白俄军队，有布尔什维克，有一些无政府主义者，有波兰人，还有我想象中的两支不同的乌克兰民族主义势力。所以这简直是一场绝对的噩梦。
And that continues because Ukraine has the famine in the early 1930s. So that's under Stalin. Under Stalin. Then the Nazis attack. Some of them help the Nazis. Some of them fight against the Nazis. The Red Army counterattacks. Then there's more stuff with the Poles going on.
而且这种情况还在继续，因为乌克兰在20世纪30年代初遭遇了饥荒。那是斯大林时期。在斯大林统治下。然后纳粹发动了进攻。其中一些人帮助纳粹。另一些人则与纳粹作战。红军发起反击。接着波兰人又引发了一些事端。
It's just an utter, utter, utter nightmare. And the historian Timothy Snyder has this book, Bloodlands, and Ukraine is absolutely the centre of this. This sort of literally blood-soaked territory where people are being thrown into mass graves and all this stuff. But amid all this,
这简直是一场彻头彻尾、毫无希望的噩梦。历史学家蒂莫西·斯奈德（Timothy Snyder）写过一本书叫《血殇》（Bloodlands），而乌克兰绝对是这一切的中心。这片可以说是血流成河的土地，人们被扔进乱葬岗，等等诸如此类。但在这一切的中心，
one of the massive events in Ukrainian identity is the Holodmor, the famine of the early 1930s. And it's a british journalist who exposes this a man called gareth jones another welshman uh there's a film about him wasn't there yeah i think by common consent of quite a poor film actually um james norton played him he's uh you know he's from barry in in south wales he works for The Times. He goes to Russia and to Ukraine. Now, here's an amazing connection.
乌克兰身份认同中的重大事件之一就是乌克兰大饥荒，即20世纪30年代初的饥荒。而揭露这一事件的是一位英国记者，一个名叫加雷斯·琼斯（Gareth Jones）的人，也是个威尔士人，呃，有一部关于他的电影，对吧？对，我想大家的共识是其实拍得挺烂的一部电影，嗯，詹姆斯·诺顿（James Norton）扮演的他，他是，你知道的，他来自南威尔士的巴里，他为《泰晤士报》工作。他去了俄罗斯和乌克兰。现在，这里有一个惊人的联系。
His mother had worked in Hughes-Ovka as the tutor of John Hughes' son. Only connect. Isn't that bizarre? It is bizarre. And then he doesn't have a massive interest in Russia. He studies French, Gareth Jones, I think at Cambridge, and then goes to work for the Times and ends up being sent back to this place
他的母亲曾在尤索夫卡担任约翰·休斯儿子的家庭教师。真是无巧不成书。这不是很离奇吗？确实很离奇。然后他对俄罗斯并没有产生多大的兴趣，加雷斯·琼斯在剑桥大学学习法语，我想，然后去《泰晤士报》工作，结果被派回了这个地方——
where his mother had worked as a tutor. But purely coincidentally. Purely coincidentally. And he discovers that the famine is happening and he writes reports about it in the Times. And then probably one of the most famous journalistic scandals of the 20th century, a man called Walter Durante, who worked for the New York
他的母亲曾在这里当过家庭教师。但这纯属巧合。纯属巧合。然后他发现饥荒正在发生，并在《泰晤士报》上撰写了相关报道。接着，这可能是20世纪最著名的虚假新闻丑闻之一，一个名叫沃尔特·杜兰蒂（Walter Durant）的人，他曾为《纽约
Times, who was also British-born but had become American. Durante is kind of in with Stalin. He writes these appalling, appalling stories in the New York Times saying that Gareth Jones is lying and that there is no famine. And actually Durante knew that Jones was telling the truth,
时报》工作，虽然出生在英国但已经入了美国籍。杜兰蒂和斯大林关系挺铁。他在《纽约时报》上写下了这些骇人听闻的报道，声称加雷斯·琼斯在撒谎，根本没有什么饥荒。而实际上杜兰蒂知道琼斯说的是实话，
but through journalistic competition and through wanting to keep in with Stalin, he just lied about it. The New York Times, eh? Well, you know my opinion of the New York Times, Tom, is, I mean, there are very few newspapers I hold in lower regard than the New York Times. So there's part of me that is very satisfied
但出于同行的竞争心理，也为了讨好斯大林，他只是睁着眼睛说瞎话。《纽约时报》，是吧？好吧，你知道我对《纽约时报》的看法，汤姆，我的意思是，极少有哪家报纸像《纽约时报》这样让我如此鄙视。所以我的内心有一部分感到非常满足
by telling this story. But poor old Jones comes to a very sticky end. He goes off to Mongolia after being in Ukraine. He's banned from Russia from the Soviet Union. I'm not surprised. He goes off to Mongolia and he's murdered, I think probably by the NKVD, by
通过讲述这个故事。但可怜的老琼斯却落得个极其凄惨的结局。他在乌克兰呆过之后去了蒙古。他被禁止进入俄罗斯和苏联。我一点也不奇怪。他去了蒙古，然后被谋杀，我想很可能是被内务人民委员部（NKVD）暗杀的，也就是
Stalin's secret police. So it's a very unfortunate ending. But, you know, if things get a bit testy on the pitch on Saturday night, the England players should remind the Ukrainians that Britain has a history of looking out for Ukraine and sticking up for it when others were lying. And the Crimea. The Crimea is New England. Yeah. I mean, that would go down very badly
斯大林的秘密警察。所以这是一个非常不幸的结局。但是，你知道的，如果在周六晚上的球场上局势变得有点紧张，英格兰球员应该提醒乌克兰人在历史上英国曾有关心乌克兰、并在其他人选择说谎时为之仗义执言的传统。还有克里米亚。克里米亚就是新英格兰。对。我的意思是，那场面会非常难看
because the Crimea will be a sore spot for the Ukrainian players, I imagine. So I don't think... I think just generally, I think just keep off the topic of history. You're safest. Do you think... Actually, as a rule of thumb.
因为我想克里米亚对乌克兰球员来说会是一个痛处。所以我不认为……我只是觉得总的来说，最好还是别碰历史这个话题。这样最安全。你觉得……其实，作为一个经验法则。
Yeah. You know, Harry Maguire is meant to be a great history buff because when he was arrested... So Harry Maguire, for those people who don't know, is the sort of enormously... Huge-headed... Huge-headed England centre-back.
对。你知道，哈里·马奎尔（Harry Maguire）被认为是个历史迷，因为当他被捕的时候……所以哈里·马奎尔，对那些不知道的人来说，是个极其……大头……大头英格兰中后卫。
Very underrated player, in my view. Anyway, Harry Maguire was arrested in Greece. He was, wasn't he? Greece, of course, has its own connections with Ukraine because there were Greek settlements, weren't there? Yeah. In Crimea and so on. So Harry Maguire was arrested in Greece
在我看来，这是一个被严重低估的球员。不管怎样，哈里·马奎尔在希腊被捕了。他确实被捕了，对吧？希腊当然与乌克兰有着自身的联系，因为那里曾有过希腊人的定居点，对吧？对。在克里米亚等等地方。所以哈里·马奎尔在希腊被捕
and apparently the Greek police claimed he'd been misbehaving or he'd been, well, I'm probably introducing him now. I don't think he had been misbehaving. I think he'd been some fracker in a nightclub or similar and had then been a fracker with the police. And the police claimed that Harry Maguire had shouted, I won't say exactly, he shouted, F the Greek police. F Greek civilization.
显然希腊警方声称他行为不端，或者他当时在……好吧，我现在可能在曲解他了。我不认为他当时行为不端。我觉得他可能是在夜总会或者什么地方卷入了争执，然后又跟警察发生了冲突。警方声称哈里·马奎尔曾大喊——我不会原话照搬，他大喊：去死吧希腊警察。去死吧希腊文明。
And when I heard that, I thought, I don't genuinely believe that the captain of Manchester United shouted about Greek civilization at three o'clock in the morning as he was being bundled into the back of a police van. You know, does Harry Maguire have strong views about Aristotle? Athenian imperialism. Yeah,
当我听到这个消息时，我想，我真不相信曼联队长会在凌晨三点钟被塞进警车后座时，还冲着希腊文明大喊大叫。你知道的，哈里·马奎尔对亚里士多德会有什么强烈的看法吗？雅典帝国主义。对，
exactly. I've always been a Persian man. Circus Caesar's frame. Damn you for invading Sicily. Yeah. Never forget. Well, always been a persian man turksies was framed damn you for invading sicily yeah never forget well so i mean i i think it's unlikely that he did you see this huge skull that got discovered of harry mcguire or of some other person adam rutherford wittily said harry mcguire looked like this yeah incredible skull that was found in China. There's something that I find very satisfying
完全如此。我一直是个波斯迷。凯撒的画框，诅咒你入侵西红柿（西西里）。对。永志不忘。好吧，我一直是个波斯迷，薛西斯被陷害了，该死的你竟然敢入侵西西里，对，永志不忘，好吧，所以我的意思是，我觉得他不太可能会这么做。你看到那张被发现的巨大的头骨了吗？那是哈里·马奎尔的还是某个其他人的？亚当·卢瑟福（Adam Rutherford）风趣地说哈里·马奎尔长得就像这样。对，在中国发现的那个不可思议的头骨。我发现有一点非常令人满意
about watching English sporting teams is when they look like people from the First World War or Second World War from newsreels and stuff. And Harry Maguire has that slightly frowning, slightly pained, anxious expression. Yeah, about someone about to go over the top. Or somebody going abroad. I was thinking of the English people when they were filmed going abroad sort of people like the miners from
看着英格兰运动队时，他们看起来就像一战或二战新闻短片里走出来的人。而哈里·马奎尔就带着那种微微皱眉、略显痛苦和焦虑的表情。对，就像一个准备冲锋陷阵的人。或者某一个出国的人。我想到了那些出国被拍下来的英国人，比如说
derbyshire in the 1950s who famously went on a look to italy on a coach tour with um they packed the inside of the coach with tins of baked beans because they were suspicious of the italian food i think harry mcguire is absolutely a man of that ilk whereas um jack greelish i think looks like someone out of Dickens. Do you? I can definitely see Jack Grealish in the First World War. He does, but I think... The Joker of the Trench, all that sort of...
20世纪50年代来自德比郡的矿工，他们曾乘长途客车去意大利进行了一次著名的旅行，他们往客车里塞满了罐装烘豆，因为他们对意大利食物抱有戒心。我觉得哈里·马奎尔绝对是那种类型的人，而杰克·格拉利什（Jack Grealish），我觉得他看起来就像狄更斯小说里走出来的人物。是吗？我绝对能看出杰克·格拉利什在一战中的样子。他确实有，但我觉得……战壕里的机灵鬼，诸如此类……
He's the artful dodger. You know, doing his hair, brill-creamed hair in the trench, going off to the... Cheery... Yeah. Cheery... Yeah.
他就是个机灵鬼小偷。你知道的，在战壕里梳着涂了发蜡的头发，走向……兴高采烈……对。兴高采烈……对。
Very popular with the local girls in the bombed-out French town that they pass through. And Harry Kane looks like a Habsburg prince. Yes, he does. Yes, he absolutely does. That's a very good call. So he could have ruled.
深受他们路过的那个被炸毁的法国小镇当地姑娘们的喜爱。而哈里·凯恩（Harry Kane）看起来像个哈布斯堡王朝的亲王。是的，他确实像。是的，他绝对是。这个评价太准确了。所以他完全可以去统治。
So I'd say Harry Maguire is First World War. Yeah. That Grealish is Victorian. Harry Kane is 16th century. Well, I see Harry Kane as the kind of man who could have ruled Western Ukraine, Galicia. He could have visited Lviv on sort of imperial archduke visits, don't you think? Yeah, I think we're spiralling off here.
所以我要说哈里·马奎尔是一战时期的。对。格拉利什是维多利亚时期的。哈里·凯恩则是16世纪的。好吧，我认为哈里·凯恩是那种能够统治西乌克兰加利西亚的人。他本可以以帝国大公的身份访问利沃夫，你不觉得吗？对，我觉得我们的话题扯得越来越远了。
I think we'll be losing our listeners. So, Dominic, suppose England win. Yes. And I think we should say we think they're going to lose because it worked last time didn't it yeah it did work
我想我们要失去听众了。所以，多米尼克，假设英格兰赢了。是的。而且我觉得我们应该说我们认为他们会输，因为上次这招管用，对吧？是的，确实管用。
so we think they're going to lose I think it'll be very frustrating and we'll lose one now very disappointing but if we if we win
所以我们认为他们会输。我觉得这会非常令人沮丧，我们会输掉这一场，非常令人失望。但如果我们赢了的话——
then there'd be opportunities for a further one particularly if it's Denmark England Anglo-Danish relations or Anglo-Rich yeah that's a that's a great team i mean that's basically a podcast series um rather than a podcast anglo-anglo-check relations
那么就会有更进一步的机会，特别是如果是对阵丹麦，英格兰与丹麦的关系或者英格兰与……对，那真是一支伟大的球队，我的意思是那基本上可以拍成一个播客系列节目，而不是一期播客，英格兰与捷克的关系。
well there's one obvious will be another will be another another stretch i think um no no no we've got well i mean apart from um uh chamberlain there's john d going to prague okay so great stuff yeah great scenes we just need to see... What would be a problem for us is, I think, a Czech-Ukrainian semifinal. Because I think Czech-Ukrainian relations
好吧，有一个显而易见，还会另一个，还会有一段插曲，我想，不不不，我们有，好吧，我的意思是除了呃张伯伦之外，还有约翰·迪（John Dee）去布拉格，好的，太棒了，对，太棒的场景，我们只需要看看……对我们来说会是个问题的是，我觉得，捷克对阵乌克兰的半决赛。因为我觉得捷克和乌克兰的关系
would be beyond even your mighty talents, Tom. Well, we'll see. We'll see. Let's hope England win. But as I say, we think they're going to lose. May the best...
将会超越你强大的才华，汤姆。好吧，我们拭目以待。我们走着瞧。希望英格兰能赢。但就像我说的，我们认为他们会输。祝最好的……
Good luck to the Ukrainians. I hope they play well. I hope they... You know, to be honest Good luck to the Ukrainians. I hope they play well. To be honest, I think the Ukrainian victory would bring Ukrainians greater joy than us. They need it more. They've had a dreadful bad 10 years. They've had a dreadful century.
祝乌克兰人好运。我希望他们能踢好。我希望他们……说实话，祝乌克兰人好运。我希望他们能踢好。说实话，我觉得乌克兰的胜利会带给乌克兰人比我们更大的快乐。他们比我们更需要它。他们度过了糟糕透顶的十年。他们度过了糟糕透顶的一个世纪。
So if England lose, I will bear that in mind. That's a very nice note. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Okay, bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
所以如果英格兰输了，我会把这一点记在心里。这是一个非常暖心的观点。非常感谢收听。再见。好的，再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。